Alright..
Slippy: *sniff*
Hey don't *sniff* me..
*pees*
OOHHHH!!! That fucker PEED on me!
jESUS! (Hallelujah!)
He peed on me...!
He shit...
..He shit all over me!
Ohh.. That's where his butthole is XD
You fucking asshole Slippy.
Hey how's it goin' bros! My name is PEWDIEPIE!
So today I wanted to make a video about TUBER-SIMULATOR!
With Slippy...
Great fucking idea...
Slippy: *pees again*
OH JESUS CHRIST!
Dude!
not...
bad.
You fucking... toad.
You fucking toad..
My key.. my..
My key
My chairsly
Cheers Slippy..
..You fucking asshole.
Literally
I wanna talk about TUBER-SIMULATOR.
The game has been downloaded... (drum rolls please!)
...More..
(Shut up Slippy!)
I hear you back there!
You cunt.
Okay. Here's a little protip to you.
Protip: If your toad starts making fart noises..
Abort mission.
Anyway..
You bros.. have been..
Fucking incredible!
Beyond.. my wildest imaginations..
The game has been downloaded more than 5 MILLION TIMES!
I haven't gotten an updated number and that's just from a couple days ago.
I got some stats!
In the first day..
It was downloaded more than a million times!
Within less than 24 hours.
That's FUCKING INSANE!
It beat Kim K's shitty app! (She just got roasted!)
It beat the shit out of Pokémon Go. (But how about candy crush?)
I am so proud of you bros!
Couldn't have done it better myself!
And the app is still growing!
And we just feel... incredibly...
Humbled.. by.. you bros support..
and everyone playing the game.
We never expected this..
..and we just wanted to say thank you!
And by we, I mean Outerminds who worked on the game.
ahh.. they made a little video.
Let's check it out!
Alexandre Caron. CO-FOUNDER, PROGRAMMER: Hey guys! Millions of people are now playing the game and..
..it's ABSOLUTELY CRAZY!
Guiz de Pessemier. COMMUNITY MANAGER: It's incredible how creative you are with your rooms and we love watching them!
So.. Here's the whole Outerminds team!
With just eleven.. so big thanks!
We've been working on this game for.. a little less than a year..
..And.. uhh... the original idea came out..
..to do a pewdiepie sim.. ahh.. a youtuber simulator..
because.. ahh..
There weren't any at the time!
OKAY!?
And then these other ones came out and stole my likeness..
But now we have an actual one and it's actually good!
It's obvi...
I feel like an asshole saying it but..
uhh.. it is alot of work to get something like this out there..
It is a very.. very... long process
and alot of time and alot of work..
gone.. went into it
especially from Outerminds
obviously.
uhh.. I'm so thankful for all the hard work they put into it
The fact that you bros are enjoying it..
means more than anything.
at this point.. the fact
seeing so many of you bros..
..playing the game..
..having fun with it..
I think that's incredible..
and it feels so fantastic to have a..
..product out that you bros really.. really.. really enjoy.
I'm really.. really proud of that, and I'm really, really proud of Outerminds
That being said, we are gonna update the game..
We are gonna keep adding features to it..
..and we're gonna keep you guys entertained
If you haven't checked out the game already..
..I recomend you do so right now! (#shamelesspromotion)
We have alot of plans for the game.
The online features are gonna be... added soon..
When the game launched... uhh..
There we're over... almost half a million people playing it..
at the same time..
and our poor servers.. (Here it comes!)
or basically fried potatoes at this point.. (come on..)
They we're just fucked! (There it is!)
They were just completely FUCKED!
So we're still working on getting the online features back..
Outerminds literally slept at their studio..
..just to kinda get things back working..
..it is still just a small studio.
It's not like a fucking.. Triple A thing..
..and we're still out performing these big companies.
which is really cool! I'm really...
..really proud of that.
*stutering*
..I'm still..
fina..
..kinda..
..can't get over the fact that Slippy took a shit.. twice.
*stutering again*
you kinda have that.. quelching
..that feeling here..
that you wanna throw up..
but your kinda keeping it in.. trying to keep composed..
..you know..
*almost throwing up*
ah.. it came all over my keyboard
So while the servers are being fixed..
..I'm announcing a competition!
..for you bros for the next week!
If you have the game..
..I want you to post a screenshot..
..of you.. of your setup..
..and make it funny..
..make it something that would make me laugh!
That's all I want.
so post it in the link in the description..
Take a screenshot and post it there..
And.. uh.. I will review them for another time!
And the winners..
..Will get!
Get this guys..
VERIFIED!
was that..?
The winners will get verified!
Just don't spam the forums.. (RULE #1)
JESUS
FUCKING
CHRIST
Are you spaming the forums?
Yes you are spaming the forums.
Stop spaming the forums
I just got the image of..
..The liquid coming out of.. (my ass?)
Slippy's asshole and it won't go away.
If you wanna add each other in the game..
I recommend you say the hashtag™
#TuberSimulator
And I recommend checking out the forum..
..talk to other people
DO NOT CREATE A SEPERATE FUCKING THREAD! (RULE #2)
JESUS CHRIST!
STOP DOING THAT.
And yeah.. that's.. that's what I want you to do.
That being said, you bros fucking kick ass
JESUS (Haleluja!). I'm so impressed!
I have a million followers in the game
it's fucking retarded
I can't believe that this is happening...
I'm so happy
I feel so lucky
You bros are fucking awesome
Thank you for playing the game!
Now keep playing it!
Cause we are gonna be fucking ri..
I'm kidding!
Not even making that much money of the game (o rly?)
*fake laughing*
But yeah that's it for me for now
check out.. check out TUBER-SIMULATOR
It's in the description
and I would kiss my..
..hands but I can't
You know.. Slippy
Are you gonna be ok?
Are you gonna be ok for the outro?
I think maybe I..
I squeezed his belly a bit too hard
you know?
Don't.. shit
Oh, he's doing that thing again
I'm holding him like this now
Alright Slippy!
You take the outro!
Please don't shit..
Please don't shit.....
I'm looking at.. straight at his asshole
oh!
Alright..
He's gonna shit.
he's gonna shit!
he's gonna shit.
Yeah take a fucking bath, you fucking bitch.
They don't tell you this in toad school...